this is going to be navigating Google
cloud platform if this is not the
session you're supposed to be in you've
waited a long time before for a big let
me give a quick intro I am going to
reveal a little bits and pieces of
information about me over the course of
this talk but I want to know who you
guys are
so how many people in this room spend
most of their time at work developing
okay how many spend most their time
working on systems being assisted min
okay how many do both
because you love DevOps your company
will hire more people which okay how
many people tell developers or systems
people what to do oh all right I cut a
lot of jokes which is fine I got to cut
a lot of manager jokes it's fine because
we were running short on time all right
so Michael with this session is
specifically to help developers and sis
admin's
to figure out if you're new to GCP to
figure out how to find the solutions to
your problems I am NOT going to talk
about us relative to competition too
much I'm kind of it's just too much to
do so I'm going to sort of take the
baseline assumption that you're already
you're already on board I understand
that may not be the case but as a
pleasent fixes that we'll just all sort
of share together and we'll be fine
my other goal is to not show off our org
chart too much which is difficult
because most of our leadership are in
fact blue hexagons with weird figures on
their faces luckily they've lucked into
a job here where they can be that we
have a lot of products we have a lot of
a lot of things and they all have names
and those names may or may not be
descriptive of what they do cause
reasons right so my goal is to get you
from looking at this big chart and
feeling like this to being able to find
what it is that you want to talk about
what you want to use also some of this
is more complex than other parts of it
what computing you use ah what what is
going on
there we go whoever its messing with it
stop so some of this is more complex
than other things so I'm going to start
talking about computing I'm an
application developer by by trade and so
I want to spend a lot of time talking
about processing and doing things then
I'm going to go into networking storage
I will talk a little bit about Big Data
but I will warn you that as an
application developer I don't do a lot
of big data so you're going to get c+
answers if you probed me which we may
not have time for which is kind of good
I shouldn't have admitted that we have
also we're gonna talk about
administration and development and then
finally because it we have to do it by
law we're Google conference we should
talk about machine learning so I am
going to focus on computing and storage
because there are difficult questions to
answer in those two spaces like which
which things should I use for this
whereas with networking administration
development it's a lot of like let me
find the right tool for this particular
thing let me just what's its name
and then finally a machine learning
you're going to hear a lot about machine
learning at this conference so I feel
like I can kind of give a very very I
don't have to go to too deep with
machine learning even though you know
with any of those ones any of these
icons we had up each one of these could
be an hour long talk so or more or a
whole conference depending you know on
what we're talking about so with that
I'm going to get into computing or doing
things so when you talk about computing
you're usually talking about one of
three things in this space
it's not about virtual machines so I
have stuff that runs somewhere else I
would like it to run here how do I get
it to run here we have containers since
everything is moving to containers as we
were completely told constantly
constantly by the zeitgeist and then
finally serverless
server list is for we don't want to deal
with the underlying infrastructure we
just want to write code and push it
somewhere now those of you that have
been following the space for a while you
may know that we talked a lot about
platform as-a-service a couple years ago
and the dirty secret that no one's going
to tell you is that since our phalanx
black service but for people who have
kind of fallen into the Gartner trial of
disillusionment so I'm going to call it
server list so you're not afraid of it
but server list is another pass and
we'll talk about our solutions then so
let us start with the virtual machines
they're pretty straightforward they are
virtual machines you can choose one from
64 processors you can go all the way to
point 6 gigs of ram all the way up to
416 and basically you're you're bound by
how many processors you use you have to
use a minimum of 0.9 to a maximum of six
point five gigs per processor those of
you are looking at the slides carefully
and doing that doesn't add up we can we
have one or two configurations that have
less than 0.9 gigs of ram yeah disk to
it you can add simple persistent storage
you can add SSDs you can add Ram disks
you can also I don't know if we
announced that yet so I'm going to add
that we also have you can build off of
our pre-configured images so Debian
Ubuntu Red Hat other other flavors of
Linux and Windows you can customize
those images and save them or you can
even upload your own images and we like
to say that our VM spit up in tens of
seconds what do we mean by that we mean
that when you're in our hotel room
testing the night before they spit up in
20 seconds when you're in front of a
crowd of people they spit up in 40 I
don't know how they know I think it
would be in their best interest to spit
up quickly in front of guests but they
do what they do and you'll see that in a
minute now this is I just want to blank
VM I want to build it myself it's fine
you get that but a lot of times people
want to fool around something already
built like I want a wordpress install I
want a [ __ ] DB set up already for me so
we have a tool I can do that called
cloud launcher we have images that are
available so for many and most common
software packages you're just going to
be able to go there and load them up now
we don't manage them for you after you
run them in cloud launcher it's as if
basically you spun up a VM did all the
configuration work and you're at the
same spot so just a jumpstart
so I'm going to quickly show a demo of
compute engine his demos are fun so this
is compute engine this is the interface
for it I'm going to go ahead and create
an instance and show you some of the
options here so I'm going to customize
this I'm going to build it with as many
cores as I want a little less memory and
this is great like we have pre-built
sets if you go back to the basic view
you can set very particular things but
let's say you need somewhere between 8
and 16 cores you can get that dial it in
very specifically so I'll go to 12 there
we go I can choose my image to do all
that I'm going to go and create now
we'll see if it creates in time but I'm
going to use the image i julia child
last night yes I used Julia Child as a
verb and you'll see that uh I didn't
pull down any certs I didn't fire up my
own terminal I just went to the browser
and I am browsing directly and now which
one's going to come up first SSH or Oh
the instance popped green so it was
ready we weren't watching it fully so it
kind of was like okay maybe I'll spin up
fast alright and there we are and now
our command-line SSH I can do whatever I
want on this VM that click that easy
alright thank you yeah I love I love SSH
to the browser it is life changing when
it when you get it alright so now we're
going to move on to containers how many
people here are fooling around with
containers already ok how many are
running them in production okay how many
have said the word doctor in a parking
lot and a conference sprung up around
you it happens all right so good all
right so containers is another pass for
virtualization is a alternative to
virtualization instead of carving off a
whole machine and using all the
resources dedicated to a VM you
basically fool all your hosts so are all
your containers into thinking they're
the only machine running and so you can
split off processes and start things up
really really quickly for those that
aren't as as full run on containers yet
that was a very quick explanation
containers so containers at Google first
thing we talk about is container and
which is managed kubernetes which leads
to the obvious question Cooper weddings
kubernetes is a container orchestration
system meaning if you want to just spit
up one container Dockers great if you
want to spin up gigantic sets of
interconnected containers that need
complex networking that goes between
them to allocate resources and services
between them it gets complicated and big
so here's like a three-tier app right I
want to spin up a single instance of a
database that we would call a we call it
I would call it a pet set but we call it
something else now but it's a pet right
like I just want one and then I've got
the API layer which is multiple versions
multiple processes running for the API
layer and a front layer all of these are
wired together if one of them goes down
it will because I said I want four of
the middle layer it's going to make sure
that they're always for running so if
one goes down in a resurrect and this
allows you to organize your containers
into what we call workloads now workload
could be microservice which is a lot of
what containers have been known for but
it also be things like scheduled jobs or
batch jobs anything where you need to
spin up large amounts or small amounts
of the same process over and over again
the containers and kubernetes could be a
good solution for you now this is
running on top of kubernetes but from a
systems perspective here's what you have
to do to run kubernetes you have to
build up your machine you have to pick
the OS pick where you're going to run it
on Prem another cloud provider or us we
would love to have your business
and then you have to install kubernetes
on them and then once you install
kubernetes you have to set up a network
you get to make sure that network is DNS
which helps with service discovery you
then set up logging and monitoring
because those things are sorts of things
we like to know about our servers that
stuff is happening maybe you're not cool
with the fact that they resurrect and go
away the containers so you want to add
some persistent storage and now that you
have your kubernetes cluster up you have
to make sure you maintain the version of
kubernetes and the OS and make sure you
patch TLS and handle all of those
updates and all of that
hell that meaning or there's this little
box called container engine and there's
like a little box right there says
create a container cluster for me and
that that's all you have to do but all
of that thing all of that explanation I
did or you just press that button so we
like to say that oh I was going to do a
quick demo of container engine see I
have a terminal of them ready all right
so I'm just going to I'm going to run
one command I'm going to show you this
visualizer
so this visualizer is is right now
looking at the containers that are
running on my kubernetes cluster I'm
going to run on a command to get deploy
and we should see zooming the network
gods have been there we go the network
gods have been appeased and so I am
building multiple systems at the same
time I am building four database servers
that power seven front ends two copies
of Drupal one copy of a custom app and
nodejs app WordPress and one others end
developer server so I just spun all of
this up all this all these machines got
their networking their their back-end
and all spun from nothing and now the
dark green ones are going to get IP
addresses I'm not other thing I have
enough time to dig into them but it's
important note that those are public and
the light green ones the sequel servers
and we would like them to not be public
and we can do that so in a very quick
way one of my apps is up so I'm just
going to collect see if it's working all
right
ditch don't have enough time I think
something's weird in the browser there
okay so that puts us here okay so that's
just a quick launching up a holds up a
bunch of different workloads on
kubernetes I can do it fast and do it
scripted kubernetes is what we call a
sorry container engine is managed
kubernetes or containers as a service we
have smart default set for monitoring
and logging DNS and service
every and we can also Auto scale so you
can step it kubernetes cluster on uke to
basically is your load goes up spin up
more hardware resources in order to
handle it or spin down as the case may
be and so that's container engine now
another way we have of dealing with
containers is something called App
Engine flexible environment now app
engine we talk about App Engine we talk
about it usually in terms of server
lists because it's a platform service
you don't ever really interact with the
underlying infrastructure but under the
covers App Engine flexible on App Engine
standard provision flexible is running
docker so you can flip a bit and say run
time equals custom and then you can put
whatever docker file you want and we
will run it as an app engine app now
what that buys you is connecting to a
lot of our resources and you get auto
scaling out-of-the-box from one who
however big you need to grow and then
you get one endpoint for service so a
lot of the work of setting up a service
kind of goes out you know you don't have
to do it so that is App Engine flexible
environment there are two helpers to
help you deal with containers in Google
cloud platform we have container
registry cater Builder container
registry is a storage repository for
docker images so you build your images
you push them up to the registry and
then there behind our security so you
can lock them down with your Google
Cloud account and you can pull them from
G key from container engine or App
Engine flexible or a doctor client
running on your own machine in fact what
I usually do is I push stuff up the
container registry I will be in
production on kubernetes but in
development I will develop on docker and
so I can use the same image in the same
builds in both places in ER builder is
brand new as in Monday it came out it is
a service if you doing a lot of work on
containers you reach a point where you
need to build a build infrastructure to
make sure that your your builds are
consistent and you're going through
whatever continuous integration tools
you have container builder will just do
that for you
and it could integrate with other CI
systems and other repositories or you
will just build it and store it for you
on container registry and speed up that
whole process so all right
that's containers move on to our friend
service service we have our friend App
Engine flexible runtime and I said it
was container technology and it is but
if you don't flip the switch you're
going to use one of our runtimes instead
of your own docker file and the runtime
under the covers is a docker file that
we built specifically for this we have
set languages built already and we're
working on adding more but it's Java
eight Python to seven and three five
nodejs Ruby PHP and go version numbers
are little muddled right now because I
can't remember if we released the thing
or not so the big differentiator here is
that under the covers like I said it is
docker so you can add extra things to
our docker file so you can add extra
software and extra configuration and
really open up the capabilities of your
machine as the Pope I'm starting your
application as opposed to a pension
standard runtime which is much more
locked down in terms of what languages
you can use Python 2.7 Java 7 PHP 5 5 go
1 6 or 8 and remember where it's at the
abilities are much more constrained for
example PHP you can extend and see if
you need to normally but on App Engine
standard you can't do that you can do
that on on flex but you you are in
standard you can add extra code you can
add more PHP as long as your extensions
on PHP it'll work fine but once you try
to dip out of PHP it won't work or Java
or Python or go now what do you get for
this constraint you get incredibly rapid
scaling and I'm going to show that off
in a second to kind of make it clear why
the scaling really is is rapid and why
you might use it the other thing is it
scales down to zero flex will scale down
to one instance and have one instance
responding to requests all the time a
pidgin standard will scale down to zero
and will not charge you while it's at
zero which is kind of a nice feature
finally we have cloud functions which
we're really excited to be talking about
there our demos out in the showcase area
that talk about this app engine your
abstracted to an app right and you move
an app from place to place but the unive
abstraction with functions is a function
why does that make sense well let's say
I've got a mobile app or some other
thing with all the logic is somewhere
else and I just need to do one thing
this is the healthy on like perfect
example of this I just want to send mail
from my mobile app you could write some
code build an application set up routing
so that your API is easily called and
locked behind security and everything so
that app can send a mail you could build
an application for it or with cloud
functions you just write the one
function that sends the mail and it will
create an endpoint for you so you can
attach to your app and so you don't have
to build an entire application just to
serve up one function so that is the the
main differentiator there and it is a
Java Script nodejs only at the moment so
I promised a demo of App Engine in
action taking load so oh the there's my
there's my kubernetes app it decided to
load okay so I have here a set of ten
VMs compute engine VMs and they're going
to hit that URL please you can hit the
URL don't hit that URL
no no because you'll you'll break the
whole like from cold we're going to see
how App Engine scales so you can hit it
after I'm done the demo if that's your
tank so I'm going to go ahead and run
one make command and I'll explain what
I'm doing I'm instructing each one of my
VM to send a thousand hits at that URL
and to do it concurrently at 50 apiece
so a 500 QPS query so I'm going to run
that whereas which back over here
someone hit the URL someone did it
that's alright you'll still see some
magic so in a moment they're going to
you see as soon as a compute engine gets
the traffic and start sending if they
start bouncing and that it's App Engine
spinning up instances of my application
in order to handle the loads that's
coming in and basically what will happen
is it can handle each instance can
handle a certain amount of traffic at
once and then say hey I'm little peg and
we'll start spitting up more instances
to take it that's how quickly we split
up instances in order to deal with your
traffic and that's why the whole scale
to zero is awesome right because it
quickly responds when you have traffic
but then when you have we don't have
traffic it starts going start spinning
down instances and three of you your
queues three of you four alright well
now I don't care now you can just pick
in a way all you want and you can see
the numbers go up in real time yeah yeah
you're really doing that you're really
hitting the URL whoa all right
I've challenged people there they're
feeling feisty so that's just a quick
demo of what App Engine can do and with
that we kind of get to the end of that
section we are done all our computing
technology you should have a good idea
of where to do containers where to do
work do server lists what the difference
between the server lists are and that
our VMs are pretty quick so with that I
want to change gears and this is going
to be more just explaining things the
networking
I mean networking is incredibly complex
but can't really get into it Nestle I'm
just going to tell you where to look for
certain things so networking tends to be
about connection security and
availability people are looking to
connect us first thing is we have
something called the virtual network
cloud virtual network that allows you to
build your own private networks for your
project and set up custom routes to
non-google locations we also have this
thing called cloud interconnect which is
kind of cool you directly peer to Google
if you are doing a lot of business with
us you're doing transferring a lot of
data back from your network to our
network it may be something that would
be cost-effective for you security from
a networking perspective two major ways
we look at this VPN which is gateway to
Gateway only for us so this isn't for
equipping road warriors with a
connection to your network this is for
connecting two or more networks to a via
secure tunnel and you can use any IPSec
compliant gateway but the idea here is
you have machines at us machines on Prem
machine
at Amazon or Azure that you want to
connect together you can use this to do
it firewall
it's a firewall like you set up rules
yeah nothing's crazy the reason why I
bring it here is because this is about
discovering things when I first started
using compute engine one of the problems
I had with sugar and like how the hell
do I open up a port like I just want to
open up some random port as one does and
you have to basically go through
networking to find the firewall settings
to create firewall rules that you can
then apply in compute engine but it is
maybe less than intuitive the first time
you come to it I want to make sure to
call it out look in the networking
section of our of our app of our console
there's what we call it to find these
things at some point someone says well I
want something that you don't have what
what can I do well you can in compute
engine build anything you want by hand
and we actually have in cloud launcher
VM setups for Barracuda brocade cloud
feller and a whole bunch of others I
clearly went alphabetical in my list and
you can build you can build these and
you can manage them we don't manage
these for you but you absolutely can do
that now I'll talk about availability we
have cloud CDN which you activate the
interface for it is actually through our
load balancers which I'll talk about in
a second and these they basically uses
HTTP headers in order to determine cache
ability you can do edge caching and
invalidation and pre loading and all
sorts of things you do with content if
you want to do more complex things this
is not the solution for you this is a
there's not meant to be a comprehensive
solution it's people want this as part
of a basic cloud package we offer it if
you need more complex things we have
partners that are more than happy to
talk to you about doing more complex
things with caching with us and then so
next is DNS
this is interesting in that it is the
only thing I've ever seen where we
promise 100 that we have promised 100%
availability our SLA is 100 percent of
availability and adds like doubled is it
didn't round up somewhat no the honor
presented availability for our DNS
service
so something to keep in mind that's
interesting and then finite are load
balancers a lot of people talk about
load balancers in terms of l4 versus l7
we don't we talk about HTTP and SSL load
balancers which do what you'd imagine
they do internal is for load balancing
traffic that would not leave our network
so a lot of times people want to load
balancing of internal services we can
now do that and the finally network load
balancing is for bouncing more than just
HTTP traffic all right my first
auctioneer section is done so now I'm
going to move on to storage we're go a
little bit deeper and talk about why you
would use one versus the other and
whatnot so with storage we tend to be
thinking along three lines files we
heavily encourages use the word blob but
as an adult human I really don't want to
get up on a stage and say the word blob
over and over again but I did so they
tricked me so they won but think of this
in terms of documents of images of
videos of audio file like their files
they're not the use of word unstructured
they have structures they're just not
they're not related to each other that
much as opposed to databases where you
have data that all looks the same all
telling the same story and has also been
lined up and easy to aggregate and talk
to it together I also like to like in I
also think of this as application data
as opposed to files but semantics very
then finally Big Data which under the
covers is really just one of the other
two that's gotten so big that to get
insight out of it you need to run
special processes on it so big data is
just you know any one of these things
that's grown out of control so we'll
start with file storage you're storing
files if you are used to some other
provider that calls it s3 this is the
this is the equivalent to that making a
little countries out of some of the
brand so I'm being recorded so nervous
so storage is the s3 equivalent we have
one set of interfaces so you deal only
with clouds two
urghhh you create a bucket and the way
to deal with that bucket is the same no
matter what type of storage you're
talking about so when you create create
a bucket and that's it but we have
several types multi regional regional
airline and coke line I will describe
why you'd want to use one versus the
other
so thinking about file we kind of have
three areas that we look at it public
content content that we're going to
share with the world and share with our
customers process data we have data that
we need to run analysis on it doesn't
need to be global I don't need to share
it with people I want it to be close to
the servers I'm going to be doing the
work so regional is fine it's in the
same data centers in the same data
location and then long-term storage is
for stuff that at the end of the day we
really hope we never see again right so
things like backup and disaster recovery
related data and compliance right and
people hate compliance because after
what did you do shortly before you
pulled in a whole bunch of appliance
data you had a conversation with a
lawyer right so we we don't want to
touch this stuff
we need to keep it but we don't ever
want to touch it so we want it to be as
cheap as possible
so kind of putting that together we'll
start at the top and go to the bottom
name the type we have public storage for
us it's ninety-nine point nine three
nine plus five availability steel
redundant this is good for world access
content things like website streaming
video shooting audio gaming mobile and
it's 2.6 cents per gigabyte per month
and this we call multi-region for
process data we have a little less
available makes sense because it's not
geo redundant and it's accessed by your
system so you need to run big data work
big data jobs you want this data to only
live in one place and be pulled in by
owning a set of servers in one
geographic location we do that for you
it is cheaper it's two cents per
gigabyte per month we call it regional
then we have two options and long-term
storage they are it's not as available
you know you're trying to first byte we
measure in seconds instead of
milliseconds but you'll still get good
dirt but pulling the stuff
now you have to keep at us for 30 days
minimal now that doesn't mean you have
to keep it on us for 30 days minimal
right if you want to delete it it's fine
it police fine we're still going to
charge you for it right that's the
30-day minimum and it's for backup and
maybe long-term longtail multimedia
right you have a video file that's
looked at every six months putting it in
cold storage and making it public from
cold storage it's fine because it's
stored really cheaply because it's a
video files that's bigger storage cost
is one cent per gigabyte per month but
if you retrieve it we're going to charge
a retrieval cost for it that goes on top
and is one cent per gigabyte per month
and our last option is cold line which
is just as available but you have to
store it for 90 days instead of 30 days
and again delete it it's fine it's just
about the charging and it's for disaster
recovery and for compliance data and it
is the cheapest storage we have at point
7 cents per gigabyte per month but
retrieving it is slightly we're
incentivizing you to not pull it out too
often it's 5 cents per gigabyte per
month that's cold line all right so we
move on to application data and we move
on to one of the giant sites of our day
sequel vs. no sequel we could have a
whole whole session a whole conference a
whole fleet of events that just hold
conferences and sell books and online
seminars about this topic so I'm not
choosing a fight I'm saying we have no
sequel and we have sequel it's fine we
have both and we welcome both even if we
have our favorites but we have good
options on both so I'm going to talk
first about sequel we have cloud sequel
which is the traditional sequel server
it is based on our VM so it is vertical
vertically scalable to the size of our
VMs but you don't ever actually there's
no you won't see the VM in your list of
compute engine instances we manage the
the OS in
early for you and we do things like
managing the backups and we make repla
setting up replication sets and opening
up network connections pretty easy
you'll see there that it says types but
there's only my sequel as a type you can
assume that up to this date we've only
had one type and perhaps we have another
type and that I got told we didn't
announce it yet so I pulled it so keep
your eyes peeled for the rest of next
you will find in other types there I
think we just you guys are smart you'll
figure it out so I figured I'd cop to it
I can't say it but I can't tell you to
not look for it our other option is
cloud spanner
now cloud spanner is for structured data
like traditionally what you store in
sequel it is we advertise it as both
highly available and strongly consistent
which the cap theorem says if you guys
are into this sort of thing cap theorem
says that's impossible so we did is we
found the guy that wrote the cap here
hired him made him a VP and he came out
was like yeah that's cool we can say
that which is again this is superficial
session it's a very abbreviated version
of the way it happened the long story
short if you want to dive into this
topic and why we say it's both and if
that's something you feel strongly about
please see me afterwards I'm happy to
dig deeper into it but long story short
says we can we call it highly available
in strong consistent it's globally
distributed and horizontally scalable
which is great when the cloud sequel
starts hitting its vertical limit having
horizontal piece to this is really
helpful now it's important to note
there's a large price differential
between these two and the reason I say
this because I just I just helped the
startup who had been fooling around with
spanner not realizing that it's it is a
it's a it's a BMW not a Volkswagen right
like and so I would say if if you don't
have the need for it don't you know if
it's not solving the problem you're
having you're not running into
horizontal scaling problems and you're
not you don't need a very highly
incredibly high latency make sure you
read all
fine print before you spin it up if you
need it it's awesome if you don't need
it it's a giant billet about yeah
I won't get I said I won't get into
pricing but it's the next option is
cloud datastore datastore is a document
base no sequel store
it's indexable and you can make it
pretty giant we have we have customers
that store a lot of data in this we also
have this thing called cloud BigTable
which you guys follow our papers we have
BigTable we made it we made a paper
about it but didn't release it and so
now there's this thing called HBase
HBase is the open source version of it
and now we need our cloud BigTable which
we released to sort of work with it so
it is a columnar low latency database
not a lot of people use it in an
application but I leave it here because
it is a there are some people that see
it as the next a next step for them it's
important to note that this one also
like cloud spanner you really need to
need it we say that until you are
storing a terabyte of database
information BigTable is not going to be
cost-effective for you so keep that in
mind all right what am i okay so I
thought enough files I've talked about
databases and now I'm going to talk
about big data so where do you store big
data on Google cloud Google cloud
platform in all of these all of these
can you know if you've got two terabytes
of data in my sequel it's hard to argue
that's like small data right so any one
of these is our storage for big data
what you're really concerned about with
big data is tools so let's talk about
some of the tools they're big here
played with bigquery okay a couple
people all right bigquery is sort of
it's magic especially even not a big
data person you're like how did you do
that you pipe in semi structured to
structured data you can analyze it very
quickly and you can use sequel to do it
and that's sort of its special sauce
with most bigquery Big Data jobs what
you're going to do is you're going to
build some sort of job to analyze your
data you're going to throw as much
computing resources as you can at it and
you get the answer back when it's done
processing all that
data bigquery is different in that well
that whole piece of you throw was much
computing resources as you have at it
like well it's us throwing our computing
resources at it and so we keep all whole
bunch of machines is ready to go to
process bigquery queries so we can
usually see for billions of rows
performance in under depending on what
you're doing you can get performance of
a second for multi billion row queries
and in fact I'm going to show this off
so let's see here we are bigquery so a
friend of mine has in there BigTable a
bigquery storage every Wikipedia request
ever made
like the logs for every for all
Wikipedia and so every time someone went
to Tom Hanks's Wikipedia page we flip
the counter so we have those logs so
that's a lot that's a lot of data so I'm
going to go that's the wrong one
formatted unformatted here is a query
I'm going to edit it so I can run it
you'll see it's sequel just like sort of
you're mostly used to running and I'm
going to run the query and it's going to
come back in one second you'll see
that's because it's cached I was
cheating so I'm going to uncashed it
just so that we we see run the query as
if I take 11 seconds I'm calling it
might take 16 but I think it's gonna
take 11 I'm on a lot of time with me
upstairs are you for talking to compute
engine having yeah it's been out there
17 seconds so 17 seconds you process
just under a terabyte of data to get
this number this number at the bottom is
very hard to read I'm going to bump it
up in a second but first what I'm going
to do is actually put commas in it
because otherwise I can't I can't read
it it would hope you guys couldn't if
you can parse that number without
comments I'd be impressed oh here we go
we're going to run this query no no
thrown one yes canceled sorry too there
we go sorry
there we go alright now I'll run the
query
this will take 20 seconds at a lastly
for minute but long story short and I'll
show the explanation all this one is
done we're going to go through another
na what was it nine point nine terabytes
of data and it's going to go about 20
seconds this time I'm going to be
pessimistic we're not catching because I
turned off the caching so there we go
nineteen six just to make me wrong so
that number as you can see it is we
calculated we had it up one trillion 190
billion 543 million eight hundred
forty-seven thousand three hundred
eighty-six requests the Wikipedia for
two years looking at the looking at the
query the query there that's kind of
awesome and if we look at what it did
under the covers I got to shrink down my
screen we actually see an explanation
and we can see what it did is that it
started out with 130 billion rows of
data from all the Wikipedia entries it
has you see here it is it's all the
requests of all the tables it's called
and then it shrunk it down to 65,000 so
it did a MapReduce on it and then we
reduced it again to the one answer of
that we did all of that in 20 seconds we
counted up to a trillion processing 130
billion rows of data is that okay yeah
all right tough crowd
lunch is looming I know so big data not
storage pub/sub publishers subscriber
model basically allows you to
communicate between multiple pieces of
our platform use it a lot when using the
database tools about to talk to talk
about we can easily handle a million
messages per second meaning if you're
going to do less than a million messages
per second you don't really have to talk
to us if you're doing more than a
million we just like a heads up so keep
that in mind if you're starting to move
over and do lots of messaging on our
platform dataflow anybody here use
Apache beam know it's all one Petri beam
but managed so does data transformation
for you you line up your workload
transfer the data as it goes into an
analysis system and you can repeat it
multiple multiple times and then data
proc which is managed spark in Hadoop
with the added benefit of allowing auto
scaling so it makes building out your
jobs and throwing more resources or
resources at it much more easy important
to note this is a side note that between
cloud storage and cloud pub/sub you can
interconnect any one of the rest of our
products so if you're building an app on
App Engine and you want to send it to
our machine learning api's like so the
vision API does deals with images you
can directly send the image to the API
but you have to base64 encode it and
sort of not a very efficient process or
you can store it in cloud storage and
then tell cloud vision API hey I've got
a file for you and it will it'll handle
it so almost any one of these tools can
be connected to any other other tools
through these two so important to keep
in mind as you start to solve problems
like how do I build out systems this is
one way to do it what if I need
something we don't offer right we have
non managed storage solutions that you
can build by hand right or you can go to
cloud launcher and get Cassandra Redditt
[ __ ] couchdb or others did not go
alphabetically this time I don't know
what my order of preference was all
right so that is storage hopefully that
gives you a good indication of where
you're going to find the storage you
need we're coming in the homestretch and
we're going to administration so
administration is usually worried about
three things reporting security
configuration if you notice I like to
make three things lives you'll see that
seeing throughout here reporting step
driver now you will notice we have will
Paul call a whole bunch of tools we have
stack driver
which is weird because it's Google cloud
platform why is the stack driver we do
that so that you kind of can wrap so
it's easy to wrap their mind around the
idea that stack driver is actually a
hybrid or cross cross cloud solution so
you can run it on us and we set it up
automatically for you but on AWS most of
our products for for
were reporting have like a one-click or
a very easy solution to get it running
and spin it up on on Amazon and then on
Prem because all of this has an API you
can extend it with between the API that
we have and the SDK you can write your
own tools that will talk to these things
so we have got logging we've got
monitoring right you can build up alerts
based on things you're used to
uptime checks building metrics and so
forth for security this is important for
a lot of a lot of companies we now have
cloud I am so I'm not going to it's like
it could be its own talk to so I'm not
going to be dig too deep into it but
just find cloud I am you can create
accounts that you then can assign to
roles and permissions then use to lock
down various pieces of your of your
account sorry I have your of your
infrastructure so file a configuration
you're going to do most your
configuration probably command-line
probably using the G cloud or the GS
util tool G cloud is will do almost
everything but if you actually want to
spit a deal with files on cloud storage
you're going to want to use gsutil
because it's sort of just G cloud is for
management of the systems GS util is
actually for reading and writing from
cloud storage well so have an API with
an SDK for most languages that gives you
rest endpoints that are functionally
equivalent to G cloud so you can build
your own solutions of whatever language
you want and also call them on similar
to G cloud and then finally deployment
manager if you like writing massive yamo
files as we all do you can write out
your entire environment in llamo and
then reproduce it either on your own
project or new projects with network
configurations with what servers are set
up with VMs what kubernetes setup you
have and this is actually how cloud
launcher works so we use it internally
and it is available to you alright
moving on to the development developers
in general we think about coding we
think about reporting sometimes and we
like using services because then we
don't have to write it
so development we have the SDK important
to note that most of the things you want
to do you can do through g-cloud if
you're using App Engine you also want to
make sure you have app config because
the PM's tell me the D cloud can do
everything that app config can do or
they're wrong
but they're like plug-ins for any ID you
have we can plug into most of them with
tools that helps you know basic basic
code intelligence of our commands and
our API s and then others I clearly ran
out of my three-tiered icon system we
have cloud source repository so we have
managed kit that is locked with our
security you set up through cloud I am
and it works with one of our other tools
I'll talk about in a second cloud
debugging so moving on to reporting we
have stackdriver trace which is
installed automatically on App Engine
and on load balancers you can enable it
through an SDK and a couple of other
environments and I'll just show it
because it's kind of cool if you guys
have seen any to showcase demos or up on
the third floor there's one with a giant
PI symbol where you spin up and build pi
you crunch 100 million digits of pi in a
very short period of time so that
application I was having some trouble
with and I was looking into what was
going on and you'll see down here I get
pretty basic information about what's
going on the whole requests up 92
milliseconds I made a call to the
identity service and then I went made a
call to another API I can then click on
that button to show the logs to see what
was going on at the same time I can see
a distribution for Hamlet how long that
request that same request took that many
different times it was taken I kind of
see it like oh there's an anomaly versus
oh there's a whole bunch to take a long
time there's a problem
so that is trace it's really really
great
when you start digging into it it's also
error reporting for aggregating either
LOC data or stuff that you send directly
to the API it is also really helpful
sees like is this a again this is an
anomalous error or is this something
that I need
to take care of debugging again if you
use cloud repos and this you can
actually step the bug into your code and
then go directly into your code on 5:04
stuff running in production if you are
brave enough and bold enough to do that
it's available on App Engine and compute
engine in a couple different runtimes so
services we have all of these services
and not just us right like cloud has a
bunch we also have ads and G suite and
YouTube and other things the point I
want to get across you here is that most
of the time you just set up some sort of
certificate or some sort of security
between these services and your cloud
project however we have this feature
called default credentials and they work
on App Engine and compute engine but out
of the box and it's beautiful because
all you have to do is instead of setting
up a whole set of certificates and
putting them in your code and storing
them and worrying about managing that
and not accidentally adding them to your
git repo you can just say give me the
default credentials to call the service
and that's all you have to do so it
makes dealing with these services a lot
easier so something to keep in mind
alright I'm going to finish with machine
learning I am running okay on time and
so machine learning tends to be about
three things using models creating
models or extending models so we have a
lot of models that you can use vision
API for visited for Images natural
language API for text speech API
translation API use them they're awesome
if you want to take on that next step
and not use a model but train models you
want to learn clout you want to use
cloud ml engine it is managed tensorflow
which you should be asking what flow and
tensorflow is an open source ml library
that allows you to create portable
models that you can train in one place
and also trained in other places the
idea here is that you can train your
model with varying levels of GPU and CPU
power and it's ok because you can move
them from place to place so when you get
back to machine learning cloud machine
clean cloud ml engine it just changed
the name so I apologize apologize for
bubbling it's
tensorflow which does a whole lot of
self tuning and it's portable so you can
create a model on your laptop and move
it to the cloud ml and have it run in
cloud ml with much more resources that
been good self tuned so that's it oh so
conclusion so hopefully after all of
this we're now putting the table back up
that we flipped over when we solved this
there are there is a lot on Google cloud
platform and we we totally acknowledge
this and we are working on it we're
making this bigger there are 50 or so 50
something icons up here I talked about
43 individual products in this hour some
of those auctioneer call and some what
was designed to help you make strategic
decisions around it I hope at the end of
this you now know you now have a better
idea of where you need to go in order to
find the answers and solve the problems
you want to solve I am around my twitter
handle is been on all the slides so if
you need to ask me a question feel free
to ask me a question you will often also
catch me out smoking so feel free to do
that too and with that I'm going to say
thank you guys very much for sticking
around and dealing with the distich
problem and go get yourself some lunch
[Applause]